a nurse quarantined by new jersey
governor chris chr has left her tent for
main the army is isolating some person
that's returning from west africa and
the white house is claiming it doesn't
have a plan to give in the states who are
going their own way  on the ebola
quarantine right now federal bu policy
is all over the place one person who's
being his usual decisive s however is
new jersey governor chris ch this is he
said in melbourne florida today the
nurse isolated and ob administration
we took new jy new york  has now adopted
by chicago has now adopted mary as i
said yesterday
onal governor cher to mar their not
exactly as str as new jersey but they do
have a new there john is this fight
between the states
think just i think one things we
learned over  last few days is that as
long as there is an eb crisis in west
africa there going to be american
medical people going there and aid
workers going there there's obviously
military personnel there and some of
them some of them inevitably are going
to come back with ea  with e like
symptoms and that's going to present
these challenges governors ones
who const fear of their people come
back with a b or looking like they might
have a b they are going to to design
their own policies and no matter what
the obama administration says they have
to deal with that look they didn't give
in on the flight ban i think people like
governor chr who assumes this is going
to be federal policy are not necessarily
right the president wants to be guided
by science he is a man of science and i
think you're gna continue to see as long
as there are few number of cases the
white house try to hold the line
although this army thing is a little
weird because it looks like the
pentagon there
no people like chr ch other states that
are  to be pushing back and so there's
going to be a lot more the ks to be
worked out here and a lot more push and
pull between the federal and state
government that case they had in new
york where the doctor came back and went
bowling really freaked  out people in
this area and I think that kind of thing
could lead other states to move against
washington